FEMALE SPEAKER:
Welcome everybody
to this TechTalk on
Monday afternoon.
Thank you very much
for coming, and we
are very happy to host
today John Mihaljevic.
He the author of a very popular
book, "The Manual of Ideas,"
which introduces you to a
framework of finding, analyzing
research, and implementing the
best value investing ideas.
And among his great
accomplishments,
John is also a member
of the Value Investors,
and the Value Investors Club.
It's a community for
top money managers,
and he also won the
prize for best investment
idea in that club.
There could be many other
great words said about John,
but you came here
to listen to him.
So welcome, and
the floor is yours.
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Thanks.
Well, thank you so
much, [? Anna, ?]
for the overly
generous introduction.
I also want to thank
[? Sirabat ?] in the Bay Area
office for the invitation, which
I was very excited to receive.
And it's such a pleasure
to be here at Google.
I don't think I could have made
it here if applying for a job,
so this is kind of my
entree, if you will.
I want to talk about
idea generation,
and specifically from
an investment angle,
so how to find great
investment ideas.
And I put "secret"
in quotation marks
here because there
really is no secret.
But I'm glad so many
came to hear the talk.
How do we really
think about investing?
And it has a lot to do with
how we view the stock market.
Because when it comes to
investing in public companies,
you are transacting in
a global stock market.
It's very liquid, you can
buy and sell at any time.
And I think there's
just a lot of confusion
out there as to what the stock
market really is, and there
are also very many approaches.
And it's actually
in the interest
of the financial
community and Wall Street
to make it seem
very complicated,
so that you will just
give your money to them
and think that they're doing
such a great job for you
that they deserve to
get paid a lot of money.
When in reality, it
isn't that complicated.
The stock market is
a beauty contest,
that's really a criticism
that economist John Maynard
Keynes levied on the stock
market, or on Wall Street.
And it's really this idea that
a lot of investors, and even
professional investors,
will choose companies
based on what they
think other people will
think of those companies.
So everybody's kind of trying
to play a guessing game, where
basically you're picking
the prettiest face,
or the prettiest
company-- but it's not
the one you think
is the prettiest,
it's the one you think others
will think is the prettiest.
And of course, as Keynes
said in this quote,
you can take that to the third
degree, and the fourth degree,
and so on, and so on, and it
becomes very self-referential.
And because a lot of
people invest this way,
this is how the stock market
might act in the short term.
It's very
unpredictable, everybody
trying to out-guess
everybody else.
But that's really
not how you can
be successful in the long term.
And by viewing the stock market
as a parimutuel betting system,
we're getting a little bit
closer to the essence of it.
Because really it's not about
guessing the prettiest face,
or the best company, or
what others will think--
because if there is a company
out there like Google,
that game becomes pretty easy.
What becomes harder is
calibrating that judgment
versus what you have
to pay to actually buy
that company in
the stock market.
So as Warren Buffett's partner
Charlie Munger says here
in this quote, sometimes
it's just really easy
to see which horse is
most likely to win a race,
but that horse will
have odds that are maybe
three to two, that
pay three to two,
and some other horse
that doesn't look as fast
may have odds of 100 to one.
And then it becomes
much more difficult,
because probabilistically,
the best horse
isn't going to win
100% of the time.
What if the horse that
has the odds of 100 to one
can win 5% of the time,
or 10% of the time?
It may actually be the better
investment-- or the better bet,
in this case.
And this quote
from Warren Buffett
kind of fits that paradigm.
He says, we simply
attempt to be fearful
when others are greedy, and
greedy when others are fearful.
And that really
speaks to those odds.
Because if you have everybody
in the world believing
that a company will go
bankrupt, the odds on it
may be so great that if it
just doesn't go bankrupt--
it may still be a
mediocre company--
you could actually do very well.
And then finally we really get
to the essence of the stock
market, and it's just
a conduit to ownership.
So Google would
be a great company
whether it's publicly
traded or not.
It would still have
the cash flow it has,
it would still have the
customers that it has.
And so you don't
need the stock market
to make a Google valuable,
or any other company.
And so it's basically
just a place
to buy and sell
stock in companies.
And what is stock?
The legal definition
tells you that it's just
a partial ownership
of a corporation.
That's really what you're buying
when you invest in a stock.
And it may not seem
that way because it's
so easy to transact online.
You're just looking
at a stock ticker,
and it's easy to forget that
what you're really buying
is ownership of a
real life business.
And so you'll hear of all
kinds of different strategies,
or you'll hear of people trying
to invest based on charts.
They'll look at
different bands and try
to guess when the stock
is breaking out or not.
But that's basically
removing yourself
from the essence of
what a stock really is.
And when you do that,
your chances of success
go down dramatically.
Because let's say you do
invest based on a chart,
and you lose all your money.
There's no recourse.
You can say, well,
the chart looked good,
and in every other case
when that happened,
the stock did go up.
Well, there's no
connection between that
and what a stock is legally.
Legally, it's ownership
of a business.
And so if you invest in a
company, and you're right,
you can in the worst
case take the recourse
and acquire a
majority of the stock,
kick out the board of directors,
put in your own directors,
your own management
team, and take
full ownership of that company.
So there you are getting to the
essence of what a stock really
is.
And if you invest
based on that essence,
you'll be much more
successful, because you're just
as close to the truth
as can possibly be.
I want to talk a little
bit about the mindset
that you need to have to
be a successful investor.
So a lot of investors
will think this way,
kind of the small fish mindset.
Let's say I have
$100,000 to invest.
Here's a bunch of companies,
and their stock price
is their market value.
Market value simply is what it
would take at the current stock
price to buy the whole company.
And if you have the
small fish mindset,
you might just
say, well, $100,000
buys a few thousand shares
of any of these companies.
And my $100,000
is insignificant,
s so it really doesn't move
the needle on these companies,
or the market is a whole.
And the reason it's the
wrong mindset to adopt
is because just because
your portfolio may be small,
your role in the market
is not insignificant.
Because the market is supposed
to function efficiently
because even small
investors think
about how well is
company A going
to do, how much do
I have to pay to buy
it, et cetera, et cetera.
So you really need to
think about not the scale
of your portfolio, but
the scale of the companies
you're investing in.
And so here's kind of the
mindset to be, which is really,
I think, what successful
investors adopt,
no matter how much
money they're investing.
And it's the same
table as before,
but we're just showing
it in a different way.
By the way, this is
about 10 years old,
some of these numbers, so
it's changed quite a bit.
But what I'm trying
to illustrate
here is when you
look at it this way,
you suddenly realize, wow, I
can either buy all of Toyota
for $99 billion.
Or for the same amount of money,
actually a little bit of less,
I can buy all of these
companies on the left.
And that's 100% of them.
So you can either
own all of Toyota,
or you can own all of Ford,
GM, and the other companies.
And you may still decide
that owning all of Toyota
is the smarter investment,
but at least you'll
be aware what that
decision implies.
You're no longer on this
slide, where you're thinking,
oh, well, I can buy a few
thousand shares of Toyota
or some other company, and it's
kind of all the same thing.
So here you're realizing
what you're really doing.
And that mentality, to really
think of investing as an owner,
I think is very much in
line with the legal essence
of stocks.
So here's a very busy
chart, and we're not
going to get through
all of it, but there
are few points I'd
like to make here.
So one is all the way on the
left you see idea generation.
And there's so
many different ways
to find potential
investment ideas.
You may hear it from friends,
on message boards, read
about a company
in the newspaper.
You could do a
quantitative stock screen,
searching for the cheapest
companies based on some metric.
So idea generation
generally is the easy part.
And we can overload
ourselves with ideas.
There's actually about 10,000
publicly traded companies
in North America
alone, and probably
20,000 to 30,000
companies worldwide.
So there's a ton of
companies to choose from.
So where successful investors
really generate their success--
or as they call it
in the industry,
their alpha or edge-- is really
in assessing the investment
opportunities.
So I could give everyone
the same potential company
to invest in, and someone
will say, wow, that's great,
I want to buy.
Someone will say, no way.
And that's really that decision.
If you can get that
decision right,
you're going to be successful.
So given what we know now
about the right mentality
to think of a business
as an owner, and would
I want to buy the whole
company if I could,
let's walk through
this a little bit.
So a company will
usually have real assets,
especially if it's
kind of an old school
company that maybe
has factories.
Let's take a General Motors.
They've got
factories, they've got
all kinds of tangible assets.
You would want to ask whether
this company, at the stock
price it is today, is trading
for more than it would
take to recreate
it from scratch.
And you're not going to be able
to recreate the company exactly
the same from
scratch, but the idea
is how much capital would it
take to recreate the earnings
flow and the basic
business of a company.
So if it's selling for a lot
more in the stock market,
you're not going
to buy that stock.
Because what that's
saying is there's
an incentive for a
competitor to come in,
because they can recreate
that same company for less
money than the
stock price implies.
So if the company in the stock
market is worth $2 billion,
and you could recreate that
business for $1 billion,
there's an incentive for
someone with a lot of money
to come in, create that
company for $1 billion,
take it public immediately, and
then basically sell the stock
for $2 billion in the market.
So that's where we're going to
basically eliminate the company
from consideration if it's
trading above its replacement
cost.
Now if it's below, then we
go to the other extreme,
which is liquidation value.
And what is liquidation value?
It basically means what is
this company worth dead today?
So if you were to shut
down the business,
or sell it, and
liquidate all the assets,
how much money would
you have left over?
And if a company is
selling below that,
that's usually a low
number, but sometimes
companies actually
do sell below that.
I'll give you an example.
When the shipping industry--
these big ocean tankers that
transport crude oil around
the world, and so forth.
When that industry
is doing badly,
it's doing generally so
badly that no one wants
to own these stocks, and
they will sell, on occasion,
for less than the scrap
value of the metal used
to build the ships.
So you could buy those stocks
for less than the scrap value.
And then, generally, management
of these companies, the CEO,
they'll say, oh, the turnaround
will come next quarter.
OK, maybe in a year.
But after two or
three years, they'll
start selling the ships
for scrap themselves.
And if they do
that, and the stock
is trading for less
than scrap, you're
actually going to make money,
even though the business looks
like it's going under.
So that's another easy one.
You would take control
of the company,
you would liquidate
it, you'd make money.
Now beyond that-- those are kind
of the two bounds, the upper
and lower bounds--
you get into where
you're looking at actual
earning power of the company.
And this is where
most companies end up,
unless we're in a 2008 financial
crisis-type scenario, where
there were a lot of
companies selling
for less than their
liquidation value.
And what you would
look at here is
how much is this company
actually earning,
and how much do I have to
pay in the stock market
to acquire the whole business?
And there's no right
or wrong answer.
So you would basically decide,
well, what kind of return
is good enough for my savings?
If a company's earning
$1 billion a year,
and it takes $10 billion to
buy it in the stock market,
that's a 10% a year return.
And then maybe you
want to know, well,
are those earnings
growing over time?
So my 10% in year one
will be 11%, and then 12%,
and so forth.
Or are the earnings declining?
In which case you'll want
a higher initial percentage
yield.
So maybe even if the earnings
are going to decline,
well, if you can acquire it
for two times current earnings,
that means you're making
50% return just based on--
and we have the mindset of a
capital allocator and owner
here, no longer just
pieces of paper and stocks.
If you can buy the whole
company and in one year
get half your money
back in earnings,
you're probably
going to be fine,
even if those earnings are
going down slowly over time.
Because within two
to three years,
you've got all your money
back, and then whatever
comes after that is just gravy.
So here you're making a decision
whether the earnings yield--
that's the earnings
before interest and tax--
and these are some
technical terms here,
but I'm telling you
the essence of what's
on here-- if those earnings
divided by what the company's
worth in the market exceed
whatever return you require--
because you're going to look
at your alternatives, right?
You can put money in a
CD, you can buy a bond,
you can do all kinds of things.
If that exceeds your
return, you move on here.
If it doesn't, you eliminate
this particular company
from consideration.
And now what we're
talking about here
is we're looking at the
business itself now.
Forget the stock market.
We just want to know how
good is this company.
And because we're
dealing with money here,
we want the company to make
as much money as possible
in earnings or cash flow
relative to the capital it
takes to build that company.
So if I need to have a factory
that costs me $1 billion,
and that factory is then going
to throw off $10 million a year
in profit, that's
probably not good enough.
Because that's a 1% return,
and a factory is no CD,
it's not a safe
investment, and so forth.
So you really want to know
how good is the business.
Google, for example, doesn't
take a whole lot of capital,
and it throws off a
lot of free cash flow
relative to that
capital, so that's
why it's a great business.
And that's the kind
of business you
want to be in, because
when you buy a stock,
they're not actually going to
pay you out all their earnings
every year.
Now if they just took their
earnings and paid them out,
you may not even care
how good of a business
it is, because you're
getting those earnings.
Like I mentioned, if
you're buying a company
with a 50% earnings yield,
and they paid everything out,
you got your money back in
a little over two years,
and that's fine.
But because most companies will
actually retain those earnings
in the business, you
care very much about when
they retain those earnings.
They're going to invest
them in their business,
and what is the return
on that capital?
Some companies pay
dividends, so that's
a portion of the
earnings, usually.
They won't pay out
their whole earnings,
they'll pay out half,
if you're lucky.
So there you may care
a little bit less,
because you are
getting some cash back.
But where you're not
basically getting cash back,
you want to know
what kind of return
is this company getting
on the cash that
stays in the business.
And if it's a great business,
like Google, the problem
actually becomes that it's very
hard to reinvest that cash,
because the business doesn't
require a lot of capital.
So take one year's worth of
free cash flow for Google.
If it could be reinvested
in the business
at the kinds of returns
that Google is currently
getting on its capital,
that would be phenomenal.
But because it's not a
capital-intensive business,
that free cash flow just kind of
builds up on the balance sheet,
and over time
there's tens and tens
of billions of cash
on the balance sheet.
So if we like the
quality of the business,
as measured by the earnings
divided by the capital employed
in the business, then it's a
good potential opportunity.
And it still doesn't mean
that it's a great investment.
But you've kind of eliminated
all the obvious candidates
that are just not good enough.
And then once you're here, it
becomes really more of an art,
which company you are going
to invest in versus another.
And we're going to get
into some of that here.
So here are some value-oriented
investment approaches.
You might have heard of value
investing and growth investing.
So growth investing,
usually it's
kind of the other mindset,
or just the mindset
of which company is
going to grow the fastest
and that's where
I want to invest.
But you're not really
thinking, well,
what if everyone
else thinks it's
going to grow the fastest
as you're super expensive.
You may not make any money.
If they have any kind
of disappointment,
like they missed a
quarter by a penny,
the stock can be
down 20% in a day,
because there was
just no value there.
So we want to buy things that
are more valuable than what
we're paying for them
in the stock market.
And some of the well-known
approaches in this area--
there's the Benjamin
Graham style, deep value.
And I start with that because
Benjamin Graham wrote the book
on value investing.
It's called "The
Intelligent Investor."
And the style is today
called deep value
because you focus
mostly on the assets--
like I mentioned
a shipping company
with their ships
and the scrap value.
That would be deep
value, if you can
buy something for
less than the assets.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a question.
How would you find [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Correct.
So really what you're
going to look at
is the financial
statements of a company,
and that's where we get kind of
into the language of investing,
which is really accounting.
So every company will have
a line item on their balance
sheet called property,
plant, and equipment.
And for a shipping
company, that's
where their ships might be.
For a hotel company
that owns hotels,
that's where their
hotels would be.
And then they may have a
footnote in their annual report
that actually lists
out the ships.
It won't necessarily
tell you the market value
of those ships,
but it might tell
you what they're
carried on on the books,
and how much they've depreciated
so far, and some detail.
But you're going to have
to dig a little bit deeper
if you want to know the market
value of specific ships,
or specific real estate,
or something like that.
AUDIENCE: John, can you
repeat the question?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Yeah.
The question was,
how do you actually
find companies that
maybe have those ships
and trade for less than that.
So you could use a
quantitative stock screener
that looks for companies
that have market
value less than
tangible book value.
And tangible book
value is once you
satisfy all the liabilities--
like the debt-- what's
left over for the shareholders,
using this accounting
language-- which
is standardized,
but it's not really correct
in an economic sense.
But you can use
it for screening,
and then you have to do your
own research to decide, well,
the book value may be high,
but that's not actually
if I wanted to sell the ships,
so you take it down and do
that kind of analysis.
Now Joel Greenblatt is a
very successful investor.
He's written a book called
"The Little Book That Beats
the Market," where he talks
about this magic formula.
It's essentially a way to screen
for companies that, according
to my previous
schematic, would be
in that green
portion at the end,
and then you can invest in them.
And it looks at two factors.
One is the high earnings
yield, how cheap is a business.
And the other is the
high return on capital,
how good is a business.
And historically, just
a mechanical screen
of those companies that rank
highly on those two metrics
has outperformed the S&P
500 by several percentage
points a year.
And over time, due to
compounding, that just
is a huge number.
Then we have what I call
here Carl Icahn-style,
sum-of-the-parts investing.
You may have heard
of Carl Icahn,
or these activist investors,
who will buy a big chunk
of a company-- maybe 10%-- and
then try to tell the company
what to do so that the stock
would be worth more, or go up.
And usually what
they look for is
where you have a company that
has different parts to it,
and if you add up the
value of all the parts,
it's materially above
what the whole company
is trading for in the
stock markets today.
And that can happen quite often,
because maybe a company has
a core business, and that's
what investors are focused on,
and they value the
company based on that.
But then there may
be something else
that they own that's totally
unrelated-- like some big piece
of real estate, or
some other business.
And then there are
some other approaches,
what I call jockey
stocks, which is really
companies that are
run by a great jockey.
It's again the horse
racing kind of analogy,
where you have a CEO who is
not just great at running
the business, but also great
at what he does with the cash
that the business generates.
Because once the cash is there,
there are a lot of options.
And you can destroy a lot
of value is a company,
or create a lot of value, based
on what you do with the cash.
So it's especially
relevant for companies
that have a ton of cash
on their balance sheet.
You might make an
acquisition, you
could overpay for
another business,
just because you
fear you're going
to miss out on the next trend.
And you take that
hard earned cash
and you could
basically waste it.
Or if your stock
price gets low--
let's say there's a financial
crisis and the stock gets hit,
and it's trading
way below what it's
worth-- the company could
actually take the cash hoard
and buy its own stock
in the stock market,
and create huge value.
Because if it's
just sitting there,
the cash is maybe
earning 0%, 1%, 2%.
But if you're buying your own
stock at yields of 10% or more,
you're going to
create huge value.
So I want to maybe get
into a couple of these
quickly, and then
take questions.
But these are basically these
buckets we just talked about.
And I'm not a huge
fan of buckets,
because once you
get into that, then
it becomes a little
bit more mechanical.
You find a company, and
all of a sudden you're
thinking, well, what
bucket does it fit in?
And how do I have to analyze it?
When really it should
just be common sense.
You should just take
a company, imagine
you own the whole thing,
and think like an owner,
basically, from scratch.
But nonetheless, let's
just touch on some
of the key features of some
of these types of companies.
So these deeper
value companies where
you're buying maybe some
factory-type business
for less than it would
cost to create the factory,
these are generally
hated stocks.
And if you look at
it historically,
people have overreacted on
the negative, generally.
So this guy, Jeroen Bos,
he's a successful investor
who just invests in
these hated companies.
So he says it's kind
of contradictory
that you buy what no one else
wants, and then you outperform.
And it just takes
a certain mindset
to be comfortable doing that,
because everyone around you
will say, oh, you
are not very smart.
And imagine if an
investment doesn't work out,
you're really going to
not feel very smart.
Because everyone was telling
you all along, and then that's
what happened.
So even when people
start off like this,
they can't sustain
it for very long.
Because after a while they
just think, you know what?
It's too hard, and
I can handle it,
so I'm going to move on to
one of the more comfortable
approaches, where you
buy great companies,
and you pay more for them,
but at least no one's
going to tell you that you're
making an obvious mistake.
But then, they
actually do outperform.
And it's kind of the reward for
the discomfort, if you will.
These are some takeaways that
I basically have in the book
related to this
chapter on deep value.
And I'll just kind of
highlight the first one,
which is we start with
the price of the stock.
So when you talk to
Jeroen Bos, or one
of the other investors who focus
on these kinds of companies,
the first thing they'll talk
about is wow, this is so cheap.
And then after two minutes,
you ask them, well,
what does the company do?
So they really just care
that it's really cheap,
kind of the bargain
basement pricing.
And here's an
example of a company
that somebody presented at
one of the online conferences
we've hosted for investors.
And the basic thesis here-- this
is a tire manufacturer in Korea
that has a few different
types of stock,
so it gets a little complicated.
But basically, you can
invest in this company
in a few different ways, and the
basic way-- the common stock--
is cheap.
But then there's another way,
through the preferred stock,
where you're getting this
exact same thing 50% cheaper
than other people are
paying for the other thing.
And the other thing
they're paying more,
basically because it's a little
bit more well-known, or has
more trading going on.
So sometimes people will
care about liquidity a lot
in a stock.
Oh, can I buy $10 million
of this in one day,
or does it trade very little?
When actually,
how much it trades
has nothing to do with
how much it's worth.
I mean, if you own a
house it trades zero,
and it's still worth
whatever it's worth.
So the preferreds trade at a
big discount to the common,
and that's just an example
of a deep value investment.
AUDIENCE: John, can you go
back to the previous slide?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Sure.
AUDIENCE: One quick question.
On point number two, you
said no voting rights,
but confer some
economic benefits.
Can you explain that point?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Sure.
So depending on
the class of stock,
the voting rights may be
a little bit different,
which just means do
you get to decide
who is on the board of
directors, and so forth.
And companies do that
for different reasons.
Actually, Google has,
I think, two or now
three classes of stock.
And the purpose there
is really to make sure
that the founders
retain operating control
of the company, and can
make the decisions that
are needed for the future.
Because you wouldn't necessarily
want an outside investor
to come in and buy
up enough shares
to get voting control of a
company, and then do something
that may move the stock
in the short term,
but may destroy value
in the long term.
So one way to do that is to
sell non-voting stock, or shares
that have fewer votes,
to public investors,
so that they can never gain
a majority of the vote.
And these preferreds
have no voting rights,
but this is a Korean
tire manufacturer.
Even if you're buying the
stock that has voting rights,
there's no practical
difference, because you're not
going to be able to influence
it in any way, either way.
So the voting rights
are not worth very much,
but you're getting the
same economic benefits.
So if the common
shareholders get $1 dividend,
you'll get $1 dividend, but
you're paying half the price
for the preferred stock.
Sum-of-the-parts, there are
many examples of this kind
of-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Yeah,
that's a great question.
And actually they can stay
cheaper for a very long time.
Sometimes a company may, if
the company's smart, or cares
about the value,
they may actually
buy that preferred
stock themselves,
because it's so much cheaper
than the other stock.
They could sell the other
stock in the market,
and then use the money to
buy back the preferred.
But absent that, you're right,
the disparity could continue.
But would you rather buy
the one at 50% discount,
and maybe it stays at
a discount, maybe not.
The discount could get wider,
but I think probabilistically,
you're much better off
buying it at a discount.
And it turns out
that over time, they
do tend to work out, because
some large shareholders would
move in, and they'll just
kind of start putting pressure
on the management to
eliminate this disparity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Absolutely.
And sometimes preferred
stock-- or often-- it's
a better security because it
ranks ahead of the common.
In case of bankruptcy, it
may have certain preferences.
But because a lot of investors
are so focused on liquidity,
meaning being able to--
if I decide tomorrow,
I want to dump
this stock-- being
able to dump it in one
day, versus taking a week
to sell it slowly.
They put such a premium on
that, that the preferred-- even
though it's a better security--
may trade at a big discount
to the common.
And to a long-term investor
that makes no sense.
So you can buy that preferred
slowly, you can sell it slowly,
and over time you're
going to make more money.
There are some examples
of sum-of-the-parts are
so obvious, they're at
very large companies.
So there was a couple
years ago, Vodafone,
which is a big mobile phone
carrier based in the UK,
owned a large stake in
Verizon Wireless in the US.
And Verizon Wireless
publicly traded so just
that the value of that
stake was so great
that the rest of Vodafone was
being valued extremely cheaply.
But investors didn't see
care to see it for a while,
and it's hard to
predict these things,
but usually it
works out, and then
after a couple of years, all
of a sudden it worked out,
and you actually
make a great return.
Even though you
didn't quite know when
that disparity would be removed.
And so, sometimes it makes sense
to analyze the different parts
of a company separately, and
then sum up all those values
to decide what is this
business really worth.
And I'll just make a kind
of a side comment here.
So whether you're adding
up different parts,
or just using an earnings
yield, or what have you,
you really need to
know-- or basically
have an estimate
that you believe in--
that a company's worth
before you can even
think about investing in it.
Because if you don't know what
you think a business is worth,
then there's no basis to
make an investment decision.
And I think that's
often forgotten.
Sometimes you'll just
hear someone say, oh, you
should buy Apple
stock, because they're
going to come up
with a new iPhone.
And there's no reference in
that sentence to how much
you have to pay for Apple.
Could be $100 billion,
could be $200 billion.
So maybe the fact that they're
coming out with a new product
is already reflected
in that market value--
and actually if the
new product is not
quite as great, the
stock goes down.
So you really need
to think about what
is this business worth
in the stock market,
and what do I value it at.
If I had the money,
how much would
I want to pay for that
company to own all of it,
and just make money off the
cash flow of the company.
And here's just kind
of a classic example
of sum-of-the-parts.
Where you have this little
company in India where
they got $50 million
cash, they have a big plot
of land near Mumbai airport,
and both of those things
together are already
worth more than
what the whole company's
trading for in the stock market.
So you're actually getting
the business, whatever
it is that they do-- which
is an exhibition and IT parks
business-- you're
getting that for free.
And that may or may
not be a good deal,
but at least you found something
that looks kind of interesting.
Because if they sold that
land, or gave back that cash
to the shareholders, you get
your investment right back,
and you own this business.
So that's an interesting
type of set up,
and that would fit into
sum-of-the-parts category.
I'll just touch very
briefly on magic formula,
and then we'll open
it up for questions.
Here we were talking about
the two factors screening,
looking for cheap stocks
and good companies.
Alon Bochman is an investor
who focuses on that.
And an interesting finding
is that if you gave people
the lists of those companies
that rank highly on those two
factors and told them, well, now
that you have these companies,
choose the best
ones-- or now, use
your own judgments
to choose which ones
you want to invest in.
What they found is actually,
when people choose their own,
they do worse than the
mechanical screen does.
And it's interesting but
it's also kind of intuitive,
because there we go back
to the discomfort of owning
hated businesses.
If they're that's
cheap, they're usually
companies that have fallen
a little bit on hard times.
And when you're
looking at that list,
you're going to want to
eliminate any company that
doesn't feel quite right.
But they're priced so
cheaply that they'll actually
outperform.
And so I'll end it there.
There's one more approach
discussed in the slide deck
that we're going
to skip over now,
but it deals with the quality
of the management team.
And the point that I just
want to kind of leave
with all of you is,
there's no secret,
there's no magic to this.
And the only way to do
well in the long term
is to find businesses
where you feel like you're
comfortable with it,
and it's cheap enough
in the stock market that
you feel like the return
you're getting from
the business itself
is going to make it worthwhile.
Ben Graham, who wrote that
original book on investing,
he said in the short
term, the stock market
is a voting machine.
And in the long term,
it's a weighing machine.
So in the short term,
there's the beauty contest,
there's all this
noise out there.
And when you turn
on CNBC, they're
always talking about this
quarter, or today even,
or tomorrow, what's
going to happen.
That's just noise.
There's no signal there.
But in the long term,
there's that mystery.
So how do you go from a voting
machine to a weighing machine?
But I guess over time, the
earnings of the business
come in, and people
settle down, whatever
emotion they had on
that day dissipates.
When there was the oil
spill in the Gulf of Mexico,
BP's stock got
killed, because they
were operating that
well that had the spill.
And that was the
voting machine, right?
People were saying
BP is going bankrupt.
And then as people
start to think, well,
what are the scenarios?
How much could they have to pay?
And even in the
worst case scenario,
if they had to pay $20 billion
to clean up this oil spill,
they'd still be undervalued
because the stock has gone down
so much.
And over time, the
stock went back up,
because people realized
what BP was actually worth.
So with that, I will open
it up to any questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you always have
to be ahead of the market
price, which is representative
of the current prediction
that other people have made
and according to [INAUDIBLE].
So if you want to find some
investment opportunity that
is worthwhile, you have to
make a better prediction
than all those [INAUDIBLE].
So you have to find
one where others
have made a bad prediction.
This requires
[INAUDIBLE], so is it
feasible for a small
scale investor who's
going [INAUDIBLE] profit from
it to actually be worth the time
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So the stock price does reflect
the opinion of the market.
And just to be technical, it's
not the actual stock price,
it's the market capitalization.
So it's stock price times
number of shares outstanding.
And it'll have a
prediction built in,
but you don't need to outsmart
the market on the prediction
necessarily,
because you can just
decide what you're
comfortable with.
So if the company's earning
$1 billion in free cash flow,
or net income per year, and
it's selling for $10 billion,
that's a 10% yield.
And you can say, well,
I'm comfortable with that.
Because again,
we're getting back
to the legal essence of a stock.
It's part ownership
of the company.
You're not actually betting--
there was that marketplace that
got shot down online,
where you could back
from different things,
maybe even things
like that-- how many iPhones
are going to get sold,
and if they sold above
a certain number,
you could actually get paid.
Well, that's not
what stocks are.
Stocks are just ownership
in the business.
So if you're fine with
10%, and you're fine
with it growing very slowly,
you're going to make money.
The market may expect
it to grow faster,
but that's not going to
take away your 10% yield.
It does get
dangerous when you're
buying very expensive
stocks, because there
your yield from the business
is so low that you really
are betting on something
great happening.
And that's where
outsmarting the market
becomes much more important.
But if you're just
sticking with things
that you're totally
comfortable with,
you don't need to
worry very much
about what the
market is predicting.
Yeah?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: What are the
top three to five positions
in your personal portfolio?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not going to get into
it, just because that
can age fairly rapidly.
Although I do view myself
as a long-term investor,
but circumstances
can change, and I
don't want to make any
recommendations here.
And you shouldn't accept
recommendations from anyone
really, because they're not
going to necessarily tell you
when they sell the stock
that they told you to buy.
And also, we talked
about the discomfort
of owning stocks that go down.
And generally, I want
to only buy a stock
where I am excited
if it goes down 50%,
because then I
can buy even more.
And if you have
that mindset, you're
going to be a lot pickier.
Because usually when
a stock goes down 50%,
you're really scared.
You're thinking this
is going to zero.
So you need to just know what
you think a company's worth,
and then be comfortable
with the downside.
So you really need to do
your own work, would be my--
AUDIENCE: John-- since
you're a value investor,
would you say that
you don't invest
in areas like biotech, where
the company's not public yet,
and there's no revenue?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC:
Yeah, that's right.
And a biotech company
could be worth a lot,
even if it has no
revenue, but that's
beyond my capacity to judge.
And Warren Buffett
once said, you
need to know your
circle of competence.
But what's even more important
is to stay within it.
So it can be small, but
if you stay within that,
you'll do well.
And if you venture
outside of it,
like would be my case
with a biotech company,
or many other companies--
and it's OK to say,
I don't know enough.
Actually, that's what I
would say with most companies
in the stock market.
To use a baseball analogy
again from Buffett,
it's a no-strike called game.
So you don't need to swing at
every idea that comes your way.
The only thing that matters
is the companies that you do
buy, you're right on.
And even there, you're not
going to be right on every one.
So stay within your
circle of competence
and you'll do much better than
if you venture outside of that.
Maybe go to San Francisco?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a quick question.
Thank you for a great
presentation, and a great book.
In the book, you mention about
using American Association
of Individual Investors' data to
be able to [INAUDIBLE] for some
of these buckets.
I wonder if you
have recommendations
on how one uses raw data in
countries outside the US.
So I know you're
based in Europe.
How does one do that in Europe,
or any of the other countries,
if you have recommendations?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Yeah,
that's a great question.
The data that exists
for the US stock market
is a lot more robust
than what's available
out there for Europe
or other markets.
So if you're looking at
companies listed on the New
York Stock Exchange, or NASDAQ--
even foreign companies--
you can screen for
those very cheaply.
The subscription you mentioned
is about $300 a year,
and then the databases that
will do a good job on Europe
and the rest of the world may
cost $20,000 or $30,000 a year.
So if you want to go
the low-cost route,
there's really no great
solution for Europe or Asia.
You may just end up
relying a lot more
on the primary documents,
and doing the work yourself.
Which of course makes it hard
to screen across many companies.
You'll be kind of be
digging one by one,
unless you're willing to
pay quite a bit of money.
AUDIENCE: I know you run a very
well-respected newsletter, also
by the same name
"Manual of Ideas."
I wonder, how do you go about
looking for these companies?
You obviously don't
go one at a time.
Do you use a database,
or is this names
that show up through looking
at [INAUDIBLE] equivalent
in foreign countries?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Yeah,
so we have developed
a few different idea
generation methods over time,
and we do have an
internal database that's
kind of fills in
some of the holes
that exist in some of the more
widely available databases.
So we'll use that,
and then we'll
use some of the more
serendipitous ways
of generating ideas,
like you mentioned,
some of the filings by
well-known investors,
and looking at what
they own in Europe.
So that's really what we do
is we've built that internally
over time.
But if you want
something off the shelf,
it's probably going to
be fairly pricey to cover
Europe and Asia.
AUDIENCE: So would you say
that for an individual investor
the lowest-cost option after the
databases available in the US
would be to subscribe to
a newsletter like yours,
and that would be
something that's
the lowest-cost next
available option?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: I'm not really
sure about the lowest-cost
option.
If you're looking to
screen mechanically,
the "Manual of Ideas" really
won't be the right tool,
because we don't allow you to
screen on our whole database.
We actually select ideas
and present them each month.
So I'm not sure what
service you would
want to go with for screening.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, that's
a great response, though,
that's a good idea,
thank you so much.
I have one follow-up
question, but maybe I
can come back after lunch again.
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: There's one--
AUDIENCE: There's time for one
more question from the room.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask if there's
a danger in picking stocks
that are very public,
and many people might
be buying as fanboys,
and I want to take an example,
and not just there's Google
and there's Microsoft, which
have a somewhat similar market
cap.
But the price earnings ratio
of Microsoft is twice more,
so technically Microsoft makes
twice more money than Google.
And is there a reason that
Google, just because hey,
Google is cool, they
do everything well,
is going to attract
a lot of attention
and people are going to think
oh, they are going to be great.
And the Microsoft
people don't believe it,
even though it's
making all that money.
Is it a good idea
just to collect it
as an issue or something?
Or is it just the
long term [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: So
that's a great question,
and it kind of goes
back to the parimutuel
betting system nature of--
AUDIENCE: John, could
you repeat the question?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: The question is
really Microsoft versus Google
as potential investment.
The questioner says
that Microsoft,
because basically half the price
of Google is measured by PE,
and whether that makes
Microsoft the better investment.
And it's very hard
for me to judge,
so it's really
impossible to say.
But it is true that,
as you say, the market
is making a judgment
that Google will
do much better in the
future than Microsoft.
Otherwise, you would
want to buy Microsoft,
because you're getting twice the
bang for your buck, in a way.
So just to kind of illuminate
that with some sample numbers.
Basically Google and Microsoft
were the same market value.
Microsoft right now,
the way they're valued,
is making twice as
much money as Google.
Now in absolute
terms it's not true
because Google has a bigger
market value, and so forth.
And that's just a judgment that
every investor needs to make,
but as I said earlier,
you can actually
just look at other
things if you're not
comfortable making
that judgment.
And generally, that's
not an extreme situation.
Usually you'll find much
more extreme situations
than that, where Research
In Motion is trading
at 1% of the
valuation of Google.
And something that extreme
can be also more rewarding,
if you are a little bit
right in some aspect.
Microsoft and
Google, the judgment
becomes pretty
difficult to make,
and it also may depend on your
time horizon and other things.
AUDIENCE: John, we won't hate
you if you said Microsoft here.
JOHN MIHALJEVIC:
Sorry, say it again.
AUDIENCE: I said you
could say Microsoft
if you really believe it.
We wouldn't blame you
for saying that here.
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Well,
I don't believe it,
but I'm not sure
I'd say if I did.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question John?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Sure.
AUDIENCE: When you follow so
many different investors who
are of all different sizes, in
terms of how much capital they
manage and how popularly known
outside the value investing
circles.
Who would you rate as the
top two or three investors,
not just from a
performance point of view,
but people you look up
to, and look forward
to reading their
shareholder letters,
and who have really meaningful
insights that are not popularly
known otherwise.
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Well, there
are a lot of investors I admire.
If you want people who
are really not well-known,
they're actually
in this slide deck.
Phil Ordway is somebody I
have a little bit later.
He manages a fund and does
just extremely good work.
He's kind of an
up-and-coming fund manager,
but I think will do very well.
And then there are fund
managers that are kind of not
as well-known as
Warren Buffett, but I'd
say Bruce Berkowitz
or David Einhorn,
definitely among the
folks I respect the most.
There's actually a list
of investors in the book
as well, if you
want to look at it.
And we kind of update the
list for our monthly edition
all the time.
So we want to track people that
have had good track records,
and that we know do very good
work on the companies they
invest in.
AUDIENCE: Are there specific
point managers or shareholder
letters you look forward to?
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Well,
it's sometimes hard
to get on some of these
lists, because they
manage private
partnerships and are not
allowed to mail those
letters out widely.
But Phil Ordway has a letter,
as does Michael Shearn.
Seth Klarman's letter is great,
it's sometimes hard to get.
And there are probably a number
of other guys on that list
that we could
email around maybe.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK, so thank
you very much [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MIHALJEVIC: Thank you.